il ya quelques semaines lci titre est
comique 19,2 points premier décès d'un
volontaire au test pour un vaccin qui
est un être qui était assez fa cup
puisque en effet quelqu'un est mort lors
des essais cliniques contre que vider
des vaccins contre le coc vie de 19 mais
le titre était également extrêmement
trompeurs puisque le coeur même de
l'article disait que cette personne
décédée était d'après toutes leurs
informations dans le groupe placebo
autrement dit c'était quelqu'un qui n'a
pas reçu de vaccin contre le coc vide et
si on prend chaque phrase boutabout dans
cet article mais chaque phrase est
factuel et ce genre d'actualité
du coup n'a aucune raison d'être classé
dans la catégorie écluses et ça c'est
quelque chose qui me préoccupe beaucoup
dans la manière dont on parle
défectueuse dans la manière dont la
recherche sur les faits que nous et
structurer une somme qu'on donne une
attache une importance démesurée à la
notion de fête nous as que les choses
sont factuels est-ce qu'elles sont
vraies ce qu'elles sont fausses alors
que comme on voit très bien avec ce
titre dell si c'est très facile d'être
extrêmement trompeurs de propager des
visions du monde qui sont erronés et
dangereusement erronée même en disant
uniquement des choses qui sont
parfaitement factuelle et ça j'en ai
énormément parlé entre nous quand je
parle de statistiques ou de baïse à nice
mme sur ma chaîne puisque l'une des
grandes difficultés souvent de
l'épistémologie ce n'est pas uniquement
l'acquisition de données et donc une
partie difficile en tant que tel mais la
partie peut être plus problématique est
peut-être plus déficiente encore c'est
peut-être davantage encore
l'interprétation de ces données et en
particulier on a beaucoup de mauvais
réflexes et en fait ils généralement
très difficile d'interpréter
correctement des données parce qu'il
faut notamment comprendre le contexte
dans lequel ces données ont été
collectées légalement tout l'état de
connaissances scientifiques est souvent
nécessaire pour bien interpréter des
données
en fait à bien y réfléchir chaque faits
individuels ne devrait pas avoir
beaucoup d'importance chakra est
finalement un seul point une seule
donnée et ceux qui devra avoir plus de
valeur c'est l'agrégation d'un énorme
une énorme quantité de données et pourra
analyser toutes agrégation d'une grande
quantité donné il faut faire ce qu'on a
des statistiques
et comme on l'a beaucoup beaucoup vu
dans mes fils série de vidéos sur le
bannissement ou sur l'intelligence
artificielle
les statistiques c'est vraiment vraiment
difficile il ya énormément de pièges
rappelle par exemple le paradoxe the
simpsons ces histoires de facteurs de
confusion et ensuite dans la manière
dont les statistiques sont représentées
il a également énormément de piège on
peut mettre en avant certaines
statistiques plutôt que d'autres ont
fait tout le temps ça c'est le rôle des
statistiques de d'identifier certaines
statistiques intéressantes et d'ignorer
l'ensemble des statistiques globales
parce qu'il ya eu trop de données on ne
peut pas les présenter dans un graphe
donc toute cette phase de sélection de
l'information qui est inévitable d'art
toute cette phase de sélection
d'informations
c'est là que peut se cacher énormément
de malléabilité de biais de façon de
présenter les choses donc journalistique
comme on dit dans le langage du
journalisme il faut bien voir que cet
angle journalistique c'est pas quelque
chose qu'il faut éviter à tout prix
puisque c'est quelque chose
d'inéluctable d'un simple façon de
rapporter des faits surtout si c'est de
fait compliqué si surtout celles et ceux
des statistiques compliqué il va falloir
sélectionné quelque chose à un moment et
du coup il va falloir prendre un angle
et du coup c'est refuser de prendre tout
angle c'est la seule façon d'y arriver
c'est de publier des énormes bases de
données que tout cela personne ne va
lire et même personne ne va comprendre
donc il ya forcément quelque part des
travaux de d'angle de prise de certaines
informations de mise en avant de
certaines informations plutôt que
d'autres qui seront inéluctables je
pense qu'il faut beaucoup plus axé la
réflexion sur
la mésinformation et à la diffusion de
l'information de qualité sur sept ce sur
cet aspect là sur quelle information on
en avant que les informations sont
importantes à mettre en avant
et quelles informations sont trompeuses
devrait être constaté une conso
systématiquement accompagnés de bémols
et ainsi de suite
[Applaudissements]
donc tout ça pour dire que je pense que
la réflexion parfois très très poussées
sur les faits que nous est une réflexion
qui est qui tape finalement à côté d'un
problème beaucoup plus fondamentale
beaucoup plus important est beaucoup
plus difficile également qui est ce
problème de caisse que finalement bien
communiquer quelques et qu'est-ce qu'il
faut sélectionner comme informations
quelles sont les informations qui
doivent passer le filtre des médias de
la section 2 du journaliste le filtre
des systèmes de recommandation quelle
est cette information qu'il faut
promouvoir quelles informations qu'il
faut twitté et qu'elle à leur formation
qu'il faut partager sur les différents
réseaux sociaux
je pense que c'est vraiment beaucoup
plus à la question importante
et à ce sujet je pense que le prem
défectueuse et très négligeable comparé
à un autre problème qui est le prem
qu'on appelle parfois le pommeau des
mieux tu news mme des nouvelles rendu
silencieuse je pense qu'un des grands
problèmes sur la manière dont on parle
de l'information et de lotte et en
particulier de l'éthique de
l'information
c'est pas tant qu'on dise des choses
fausses à ce sujet c'est plutôt qu'on
n'en pas pas suffisamment à vous et je
pense que techniquement la sphère timide
au brouhaha google et les préoccupations
éthiques soulevés derrière les
algorithmes de traitement de langage qui
sont au coeur de tous les produits de
google
bah ça c'est devenu à beaucoup trop une
muse alors que je pense que c'est une
nouvelle qui mériteraient énormément
d'attention et sur lequel il faudrait
beaucoup plus réfléchir à qu'est ce que
ces entreprises devraient faire comment
proposer des solutions pour rendre la
gestion de l'information sur internet
beaucoup plus bénéfique est préférable
pour tout le monde commet propager des
informations fiables est importante
parce que c'est une infection qui
mériteraient beaucoup d'idées d'être
mise beaucoup plus en avant et pour y
arriver ben c'est pas compte l'effet que
nous qu'il faut lutter c'est juste
contre ce problème
des news vendu silencieuse